more than half the people in the world
access the internet on mobile devices
instead of desktop computers
and if you just have mobile device you
can still learn to code in this tutorial
you will learn about apps and resources
you can use to code on an android device
hey what's up hi doing
welcome to this tutorial on
desktop all right so this is my first
time on fridge.com here
so making this tutorial on how to code
on phone all right so this tutorial is
basically for those that are average
system
or for those that have a system and is
willing to you know continue on your
phone once they are like out so
they are not in contact with their
laptop or their personal computer and
they want to just work on go
all right so this is actually for you so
this is where i'm gonna be looking at um
how you can get started putting on your
phone the tools are gonna be hidden on
your phone and we're gonna look at how
you can actually put python you're gonna
actually code
it's using python on our phone
all right so
without further ado let's just dive into
it
okay good so the first thing you're
going to be looking at is that um
all right so i have this phone
it has a low spec is it gonna be able to
work
for what i need
yeah i just want to tell you you don't
need to break your phone you don't need
to root your phone you don't need to do
anything you just use your phone of
course i'm gonna show you my phone
actually so i should go to my my phone
you can see i'm using
techno spark 5 pro which is just 30
gigabyte as it's full gig space and just
android 10 so you can say 30 grams it
doesn't matter even though your phone is
2 gigahertz yeah you can see
continuities
and the other thing is that this is
actually supported on android devices
i have not used ios id i have ios i
would have explored more on how it can
make use of ios
all right so without further ado let's
dive into it all right so the first
thing
we need to look at his um
yeah so before we actually dive into it
i am pressure salad from nigeria
i'm a back-end developer i build games
and application of my spare time
yeah i'm an aspiring machine engineer
and i'm also that dude that's published
recording a phone article on free code
camp so i have an article on running
python of record camp and also running
laravel
africa camp um on your phone i mean
sorry
okay so without actually any further ado
let's just dive into it
all right so just a difficult carb yeah
you can just visit we cook up you want
to learn to just go ahead and learn
since you want to know
so let's get started by looking at is it
possible
to code our phone
sorry is it possible to code on an
android phone
all right so yes you can see the answer
here is what yes you can do program on
your phone you just need to install some
app which lets you do so you can also
try the unlike compiler from
google play store as it supports c to c
plus plus so this tutorial the first
thing you're going to be looking at this
work with online compilers so let's go
ahead and search for like compilers
like compiler so we have these um
oh this is a c online compiler yeah i
don't know how to write c i don't like
to say program language but this is a c
compiler where you can actually just run
your c your c code here you can see the
aspect is i lowered
okay so it is actually
the one we we are actually work with i
think is on this id home
ide1.com or this jdo dot com so let's go
ahead and try this out
so we can go ahead and use the ido1.com
you can see this has a java here
so this is dividing we should be able to
change our programming language
exactly how you can do it so you can
have program language two to three page
python
to play on three so you guys should go
ahead and switch three i can should be
able to go ahead and do
maybe small entire print
um i'm sorry
hello what
okay
just if i should run this
you know as you can see
it's actually running now you can see
the output you have to generate it looks
hello world so this is how you can run
your stuff this is the one where you can
run applications yeah and you're also
thinking about oh yeah i don't want to
do python i want to focus on web
development i want to run
um
html css to my phone am i going to do
that yeah we can go ahead and just go
ahead and search for nobody schools
try it
so we have this try it editor for
w3schools
yeah so you can just go ahead and do
h1
sorry yeah i need and it is what is
about it is uh
it doesn't actually very well like work
on your mobile phone you will need to
switch like i think desktop mode for
this actually work very well so let's go
ahead and switch to desktop mode
all right so i think yeah that's that so
we can go ahead and
let's try and pass this out so we can go
h1
low work so go ahead and close the h1
yeah you should run this
you can see we have hello watch so this
is another way you can run
your stuff you can run your css also
all right good
and the other option there for this is
you can use codepen
so codepen lets you write code
okay to write codes and it's basically
built for front end engineers contact
developers use the right to react css
view
and then everything you want to do so
your html css this is the right place
for youtube for you to actually dive
into
um yeah once again you can just go ahead
and click on start coding
because we have html css javascript or
you have the result page
so why you write here
it's actually where it's going to be
results so let's try and do h6
and you can see it's how to load by
itself
switch out you don't need to click on a
run button for it to load
now we don't need to set to it say to a
desktop mode
you can see we have h6 which is the
smallest of all
all right beautiful
so we've actually covered
how we can run this online now let's go
ahead and look at how we actually
run
this thoughts on our phone
yeah so let's do that all right i
noticed that everything i just listed
is uh you can actually access it also on
your laptop if you have a laptop you can
go ahead and use the online compilers if
you want to
all right so i'm just recommending that
for people who don't want to use phone
if you think your phone can't actually
run what you're trying to do you can go
ahead and use the online compiler
right so what one of the lines go ahead
and open the play store so this is
google play store so the first you want
to do is always go ahead and download um
an application called a writer
and writer
so i have and writes i installed already
so let me just go ahead and like
update this okay this is not going to
update well i think i have not installed
already so
make sure you install this well once
that is installed let's go ahead and
open this up
so this is our writer yeah our writer
has
takes formatting for almost programming
a programming language you can see this
is actually jquery in this place
okay this is jquery it asks for php it
asks for javascript for html
right so the same way you are receive
copy paste
because we have this output here
we have this helper say you can see
acronym
and how to code
because we have the vr fake caption
that's everything h1286 at that
event select the html5 template and boom
you have this you can go ahead and do
hello world
so you just click on the play button
display button right under here
click on the play button in case you can
see the play button i'm just going to
bring up my brush
yeah so display button here
so you're going to click on that to run
our code and once you want to save your
code
you can go ahead and um click on this
save button here
so click on that
so once that is as you can see it has as
it does an automatic claim which is no
name.html if i'm going to rename this to
anything you want let's say index.html
select your parts
or you create a new directory
so i'm just going to save it in this
place
you can see the ads the full version
which is no as php and auto you can see
it supports php and sql autocompletion
support so it is your choice so you want
to actually get
the full version but the free button is
actually good to work with
all right
so let's run this hello world
let's so we can go ahead and do
we can do
um
we can go ahead and do uh
yeah we can do javascript so let's do
scripts
a lot
yes
so let's get our clothes you can see
these are the closing doors but of
course
so let's close the script ourselves
um that's it as format editor you can
see we have a lot of yes
all right so the same way you can also
add css
all right so you can go around that
addresses i'm not very good at css on
the back and developer
but let's try
um sorry
there's two body
background
i think this background color
should be red
let's go to close that style sorry
because i don't run this
now you can see we have this
you can see it's even formatted about
our css for us so you can assume we're
going to do color should be what white
run this yes yeah so we have this
so go ahead and save this now there's
the other app now you can be taking this
is actually good but also look a little
bit like visual studio code if you want
an app that looker looks like visual
code then you have to go ahead and
download this particular application
called
tribe edits
the stripe edit is already going to
download so i have that installed
already so let's go ahead and open it up
um distribute it right here
so probably looks almost as if like
visual studio code
it's like makes you embed embedded uh
you should study code on your phone so
you can go ahead and click on text pages
you see this which you have workspace
okay so you can also learn how to code
so everyone i click on space then text
editor i mean you can see we have
everything we need i'm just gonna
close this file these files are when i
was teaching
some students how to code on phone
yes you can see we have our open file
this is the workspace here
html css so i'm just going to open up a
file here so i'm opening this file
so this was actually i was actually
explaining dimensions css to
an htso kit using a phone because he'll
add
he doesn't have um
a laptop so the purpose of making all
this authorized so encourage people to
actually get into tech
now be able to just use what they have
right so this is it yeah so
i'll go ahead and just click on display
button here
so display button here
all right so click on the play button
like this actually this is actually it
this has also purposes you can refresh
or at least as device emulator to check
responsibilities you can upload this in
your device browser so this file you are
gonna uploaded into the browse developer
browser um
okay you said we decided to copy the
correct part first let's paste and see
it's in case this doesn't work so it's
better you just test on the app itself
and sometimes it works so let's just
like
sorry
let's like try this out
yeah there's no answer you see access
was the line so you can actually access
it but you can make sure you you can use
if um the app
so just what you want and we also have
console so how i click here because i
was like i clicked on this
so that's going to bring up your
javascript console for you
so we can go ahead and do
console.log
yes
all right so you can see you have
console.log yes i think click on the
play so you have to click on this play
button here
okay so click on the play button so you
can also have
so you can also have console
dot error yeah it is going to work let's
check it out
error and let's click complete you can
see we have error so this is actually
the javascript console
you can make use of the javascript
console in this place
all right so it's just as simple as you
so i recommend you using this app
actually this app actually serves way
as we can switch from desktop mode
to phone mode so this desktop mode here
and there's a phone mode here
all right but so we've actually seen how
to run html css on with javascript on
our phone
now let's look at how we can actually
learn how to run python on our phone so
i wrote this as a code
on writing python or phone or actually
writing channel phone and i made use of
something called pythoric
so you can go over to
[Music]
um to frequent camp and look for pydroid
so python is a python
i'm it's a python
kind of stuff that allows you to run
python on your phone so it's like like
it's an embedded system of fights on our
application generate that allows you to
run python on your phone so this is what
we're going to break away
so let's head over to play store and
install python3
so i have it installed already so you
can go ahead and install by directory
let's open it up
so this is what we have here so we have
a terminal you can see it as a premium
one so the payment will allow you to
make use of tensorflow
and other machine learning stuff you
want to use bots they can be just make
use of worldwide now so we have terminal
we can go ahead and do points
hello
what
i'm sorry i made a mistake so let's
point
hello what
you should run this uh
unexpected word
unexpected word yeah i don't know why
this is giving my error okay because we
are trying we are actually trying to run
from the terminal yeah it does it didn't
actually work so we need to have to
write our code here
a low one so let's run this i can see we
have hello world right here
so this is it this is where we're gonna
be starting our python tutorial phone
right see you next time now let's dive
right so the last time we looked away
actually we ran our hello world code
so which is this right here so let's go
ahead and save this so to save this we
can go ahead and just
click on this button right here
so let's gonna click on this say click
on save right here
so click on internal storage i'm going
to create a new story j
i'm going to call this py tools so
that's python tutorial i'm going to
select this folder and save this as
my hello world dot py so they sell water
pipe so that has been done so we've
learned how to create a load in python
so
let's look at the other things so this
prints car i'll set the string so a
string is basically it's a lower this
link is of set of characters set of um
alphabets so this is a string game the
string is just this rubbish i'm piping
and always know that the string is
always encoded either with a double
quotes like this
or
with a single quote like this and you
can say yeah i use a single quote it
doesn't matter you can use the double
quotes
i use a single quote
all right so earlier on a print can also
take same
integers so if i should go ahead and do
0.5 you can say i have five
um yeah so let's wait for this ads
yeah click on
print integer we cancel
points the bow error i said bowling we
can also place
the floating number
the photo number
oh now we can also
check the type so let's go ahead and
check our type
so we should go ahead and do print type
so we should run this
like i said i have a class of strings so
that's telling us that the hello world
is a string like i said it is a set of
alphabets meaning it is a string so the
same way we have 0.5 that's gonna be
type
of five it's going to give us a class of
ins
in so hints is actually integer so we
can go ahead and do type
type of 51.6
because it has a float so a float is a
decimal number
you know
is a decimal number so the last one you
can do is on point
type
of
true that's a true
oh yeah so true is not defined i think
it's capital letter c
yep which is a ball so a ball is a ball
and the ball is just true or false one
or zero yes or no so that's your bowling
all right so
that is covered
um let's save that
so let's go ahead and create a new file
click on a place create a new file
by clicking on new
okay
so this new file we're gonna have the
variables so what availables
variables are just uh i would like for
them i can say they're like local
storages and
where we can store information for
future use let's take a look at some
free qualcomm as if we could let's look
at google and let's search
what are
variables
in program
always make sure to name out research on
your own
all right so variables are data values
that can change when the user is asked a
question of the age variable may change
during the program execution yes so that
is to say
have a variable assigned like age equals
to 18 which is already assigned that you
can decide to change the variable
later in the future like i said i call
it the local storage that stores
information and information can change
and update anytime you want it to
all right so let's go ahead and create a
variable so to create a variable we
don't need to pass anything there we
just need to assign our variable name
and assign it to what we want to pass it
to so i'm going to assign x equals to 5.
so once that is that i can go ahead and
do points x
you can see i have five why because x is
not equal to five
because x is now equals to five so
that's our creativity it's not like
javascript so you have to do either
let's
file of course
sorry cost
constant credit variable or php you have
to assign the dollar sign no you just
have to
give it your name and equals to assign
it to the value on opacity i can go
ahead and do name
equals to
we called camp
all right so i go ahead and print
name because you have free code
companies somewhere you can do
um addition or subtraction letters you
saw
equals to two plus two
so let's do sum
so you have four right so this is just
variable and
you know you know python and the
variable can either be an integer which
is the first one i did x equals five
it's gonna be an int which is the second
one people company can be a float number
so i can delegate fl equals to
61.5
and it can also be um let's do a boolean
as you sleep or equals to true
so we can go ahead and judge you
yeah so i don't want to do if yours now
you're going to be looking at that in
the future so we can add this so the
same way we did on everything we're
going to do type of x
type of x um is equals to what is an
integer exactly so we can also do it
like that so the variable just makes it
easy for us to store information and
make reference to it back all right so
let's go ahead and save this and we've
covered what the variables actually is
so instead of going back there look at
itself so we have
this last open
here we go we're going gonna go ahead
and click on that
and say our file is there select folder
and let's name this vr name
variable.speed.pi
all right good so just so you know our
python
quality is already saved as 8.5
extension
right good so next you want to look at
is
um conditional statements in
python so we have even type of
conditional assist statement we're going
to be looking at the if statement
so before that you can see i wrote an
ask and i wrote an if so this is a
comment here
this is a comment so a comment is a part
of code that does not get executed if i
should run this nothing comes on the
screen because it's a comment i've
commented it but if i should like
or comment this now you can see it's
going to be white on sorry
i shall comment this
it's going to be white if i should run
this i should be getting an error
because i was a string i just wrote a
text and i i wanted to run it that he
could which is actually wrong so we
let's go ahead and just commented it so
that it doesn't run our code so the
first one look at if statements so this
is just a conditional statement
statement checking if a evil time is
less than 20 i want to do this
if my morning is in my morning is enough
to get a macbook pro i want you to buy
it
so that is what the idea so we can go
ahead and do creative variable money
it costs so let's show one thousand
and let's do if
money
is less than
five thousand
sorry yeah in python we don't do
brackets so it's supposed to leave money
less than five thousand
then we have to do this
let's say that's a
click on enter it will auto index it for
you if it doesn't that means you have to
specify for space one two three four
but it's also better it's always better
to just
put your color now that is auto inject
for you that lets you print
need to save more
so let's run this i can say i have need
to save my why because 1000 is actually
lesser than 5000
all right so if i should actually like
change this to
this
and i run this yeah not only because it
will be obviously because my person is
greater than zero zero zero
all right hope you understand what i'm
saying
so that is your if statement
so that is an if statement
i'll just change it to a thousand yeah
you'll be reason that okay his name was
i actually is available no you can just
pass in it here
like this one thousand
around this you can say i need to save
them because one thousand is less than
two thousand bucks always better to save
it in variable and just call it anytime
you need it so the next one we're going
to be looking at is uh if else
so else
so now the idea is that if the morning
i'm going to push this up okay
if the morning is less than two thousand
i wanted to say
need to save more
else so we have to close this indication
but once it's else else must be in the
level of the if
they add the exclamation mark again so i
said sorry not let me show my semicolon
so this semicolon is called an
indentation so it's created mutation for
us so this space is below it the four
spaces are indentation itself
so this is one two three four is an
integration
so it must be indicted for your code to
run with because if i should have this
and i do print
yes i should run this and i should oh
yeah
yeah we did not get an error because the
first code was actually true but if it
is if it was wrong
let's say i have this you should be
getting an error
um sorry
okay so let's run this as we get narrow
you see expected injected block so it
was not well injected it was only
indebted all right so let's go ahead and
just do this back and you can see we
have yes
so
which is there's a buy
mark
book
all right good
okay so let's go ahead and i'll just run
this you can say i'll buy my google
because my money is actually higher than
um these houses earlier so let's just
leave that so we also have something to
call a leaf so this is actually like
if the money is
less than one thousand i need to save
more
llc the money is actually greater than
500 i need to do this then else
so
okay so let's get on those to that so
let's do we must be in the same level as
them so i leave
morning
sorry
i'll leave
money
greater than 500
let's just print
by
hp so i should run this
now you can see how by hp why because
the first song returned the force yeah
this wasn't true because our money is
actually given at zero zero
but it now went to the second
statement which is the money greater
than 500 which is actually true because
one thousand naturally getting 500 but
if this is the circle is not true then
it's going to return the last one so i
should add a zero here making it five
thousand
and around this you can see it's running
last one which is the by macbook
all right so that is basically the
idea of if
else
let's go ahead and save this
so you can save this as a select folder
and save it as a condition
sorry conditioner
dot
right
all right so
that is that so the next one we're going
to be looking at is uh let's take a look
at how we can create
listing python
all right hey so to create a list in
python let's go ahead and create a
variable called my list
sorry my list and to create a list of
python we just have to
impose to
just create this
bracket side i don't know what this
bracket is called i think it's square
brackets yes you just need to create a
spray bracket
so you can wear that outside let's do a
pool
i'm just going to delete it so i can be
able to read that
arrange
banana
okay so let's
close that so let's go ahead and just
print
my list
like i have in seconds we have the list
printer out
okay so we can actually check if this is
the list kind of system because we can
do type
my list i can see we have a cluster of
lists so this is telling us that okay so
what you are trying to pass first to me
is actually a list
well now how can we get each of these
lists up there so we can go ahead and
get started obviously somebody by lists
and selecting the first index by zero
because in programming so count is
actually from zero so the apple is zero
the equation is um represented as a
zero
why the orange depending on one why the
banana is now two
all right that's actually our way
counting program
okay good so i'm selecting the first
thing this versus apple so i should run
this i should be having an apple so the
same way if i should select index of one
of one in this case we should have
enough orange
select index of two in this case shoving
a banana right basically that is how
this works
and we can also do some things like
chain check the length
of the list so we can do point lane
which is my list
it's not sure this is just three
yeah because we have just three
character one two three it is actually
zero one two three
all right good so um i think there's
actually another way you can create a
list
let's do second list
a post so if i use a list keyword i
don't just have to pass it double
qualifiers
double brackets and
apple
apple
it's gonna delete this i can read that
orange
oh inside i don't actually use this one
just don't uncheck it so let's close
this bracket and let's print
second list
where i should run this
like you can see we have it created the
list for us
um let's actually check our
if it's actually a list
okay so let's go ahead and do
uh type
type of um second list so let's run this
actually we have a class of lists so
this is actually how you calculate lists
in python
right so let's go ahead and save this
this is it is a crash course on python
if i need a photo to draw a python
george head over to the fruitcake china
go down there's a lot of six hours
tutorial python okay exactly what it did
there you can follow it on your on your
phone
there's no there's no drawback there's
nothing nothing you can just do exactly
what is there let's see this as on the
list
so the last thing i'm going to be
checking is
and these are functions you know
i'm choosing now python so let's look at
our policies
i just want to close this so free up
this space sorry
to feel this space so let's do functions
and python there's always a function in
python we have to use the def keyword
so this def keyword then followed by the
name of our function let's say hello
then the brackets
uh
see a load and the buttons i'll go ahead
and do this for you sorry not no bracket
i need so this there's a print
yes
hello
let's run this yeah so we have an error
that says
i'm sorry
okay i'll tell you how to point out
because of noise um sorry
yeah we are turning the bracket i i
think i forgot that here we need a
bracket sorry about that so every
function is a parenthesis around it so
let's run this you can see nothing
happened why because we need to return
it so let's go ahead and do a report
no we don't need to i think this house i
think i was quoting the php we don't
need to just have to say hello just type
it out i'll run this so you can see we
have led
so let's go around without a passive
parameter in this we are passing
so we can do hello
sorry
hello plus
space
plus name
so we need to specify we should run this
now we should get an error let's see one
required positional argument which is in
this place right here
okay so we need to pass in something
there so which is inside this here loop
so i need to pass a string as some
pressures run this
because you have a low pressures
now look at this this plus plus plus
plus is a little bit stressful there's
an easy way you can do that by just
using the f string
which is this we can still
have string and add
a quote
hello
hello so i can specify the variable
which is the name like this
and includes that but you run this you
can see we have a loop pressures
um
we should add changes to like four
which you have lo4 all right so anything
you pass in here will be returned back
and yeah before we forget let's save
this and i want to show you one last
thing
let's say this as a function
dot pi
which is your last thing let's open our
file uh now this
let's open our file
which is in the pi tool
um
it's gonna okay so this is here which is
the list
so let's try and look through this so
for i in
my list so we are looking at the for
loop here
for finding my list let's print
print i so i should run this like
actually we have everything repeated
that apple orange banana so that's how
we create for loop in
you know in python
it also has white so we can say while
or right through
print
subscribe
now it's you so this will keep going
forever because it's actually true
there's no fee there's no drawback
there's nothing so it's just keeps
running so subscribe and subscribe and
subscribe and just keep showing
you guys a while so you can actually
just dig that in too many times you can
do it and again like i said there's a
lot of python tutorial because you can
wear your look look into it
all right so for the last part of this
model
academy we are going to be looking at
some data science stuff and machine
learning store that contributing with
private all right so see you next time
all right so now let's just dive into
that so what i want to do is go ahead
about sample
now you can build android application
or your
other
android phone so i'm going to be showing
that there's another application but we
can also do that with python using
something called tv so this is a tv so
we have this kvl world so let's go ahead
and open this
so this is a simple tv application so we
should run this now
this is going to create a kv mobile
application sample for us so this is
just
another word
running on the screen
okay sorry so you know my internet
connection is on so i keep seeing this
ads
so this is it so this returns a button
of text hello world so there's a lot of
actually samples there you can look into
we have multiple slip four
for data science or
plotting of data
upon this
so you have to like install the
matplotlib directory uh the my plugin
model so let's wait for that to install
okay you can see it has installed
successfully so let's go back we can go
ahead and run this now
this is actually gonna create a plot for
us on the screen
using multiple sleep so you can see we
are running multiple loop on our phone
this is actually amazing consume these
do whatever you want to do with it
there's all these features here
right
you can also run
and software for machine learning on
your phone
yes but you need to get the premium
version so that is the only disadvantage
about that cancer tensorflow opencv and
pi touch
which is actually very very well so we
have cycling which you can actually use
for just machine learning so you can go
ahead and use this for much learning so
we have this digital completion to
recognize
um digits to classify you to classify
digits so this is just classification
um
algorithm in machine learning so this is
going to classify it
the proficient matrix and this is
everything so you're going to look into
much learning you guys start with
circuit length
to just get something today you can move
like tensorflow
and go to deep learning using pi touch
or whatever you want to use
oh yeah the same way we also have pi
game i think the beauty is giving me
this spy game um
um yeah i think it is full screen so
let's distract this
so let's run this there's a flappy bird
game due to its pie game on the phone
yeah it's flappy bird games let's
let's try this again
okay so
yeah i think this has turned to a gaming
so far
yeah so that is actually it's
good so you can see you can do machine
learning you can do whatever you want to
do i tell you about building android
apps on your phone so to build and drop
off your phone you need to install
somebody a particular application i'm
not going to be installing anything
we're going to be showing it here
but you can go ahead and check it out so
you can install something called
java
id
java nd yeah this is android builder so
this allows you to build
android applications or your phone
you can see
it allows you to build android
applications on your phone
the most popular one everyone uses is
just for android development allows you
to build android apps they won't have
tutorials you can follow to learn about
the new pc like android development
so you can get on your stories and if
you're not like that doesn't want to
like code java to learn how to do this
right and just start a sketch way so
this is just a drag and drop
stop
that's allowed to cope i think yeah i
think it got removed from play store due
to support
like no funny support so you can go
ahead and just go to chrome this has
been stored on some other people website
go ahead and
[Music]
about that download done then let's take
a look at how can you actually
write some minus command so if the data
is actually into
ethical action you will install a new
packing so go ahead and download
the thomas is a man of the system should
have on your on your phone
so this is just it's right here so you
can run anything you want to run
underneath so yeah
you have um i think you're able to see
yeah we have the key to you how to
install the gate package which were
installed by pkg i have actually run
onboard so using timeouts on my phone
before with the vnc viewer it is very
work so do anything you can do
meta spots on need to install kali linux
use vlc i just run into the terminal or
whatever you want to use
then you can also use this as nanospace
system to install node.js you can
register python install ruby no rails
install rust
just follow the lineup installation with
it's going to work on the tarmox it's as
simple as that
it's going to exist this and last but
not least i'm going to be looking at
this video is how you can create
3d game cell phone
so you're going to create games on your
phone
specifically through this you can use
strapped app so strap tap as well allows
you to create 3d application on your
phone
3d games
asset so you have this game set so the
only this advantage about the game that
it can only only the people on the
platform complete again you can you can
actually share to your friends using a
link you can actually compile it as an
application
so if you should like go ahead and let's
test out this game you can see the
amount of people the people that have
played this game that's 50 000 likes so
let's play this game and see
how it actually works
i think i should be
able to rotate my screen
let's wait for this to load
all right so this has read up you'll not
be able to hear the sound course i'm
connected with microphone right now
you can see i have the games this was
just a game created by somebody
i can also go and equate your game
um
[Music]
yeah so
there's no need to actually what you can
do
uh yes i'm about to die in this game i'm
actually very very good at it
uh else is just let's let's see let's
just collide and let's let the live
videos and see what happens wow so the
revision is insane
so let's just
minus 15
again
this is something
boom
system
yeah it's taking forever to die i'm just
gonna quit the game
all right so
you can explore this stroke app create
your own 3d game by just clicking on
dude
yeah so this was a sample game i did for
my youtube video so that was actually
important increasing the game or if you
cannot use templates available to
templates and it's them and make them
interesting like for yours
all right so
that is actually all in this video i'm
pleased
this is my first time uploading a free
program so you can go ahead and show me
support by heading over to youtube
and uh
you know what to do
subscribe to my
youtube channel i have tutorials
tutorials on coding or phone that you'll
be actually interested in and if you
want more coding or fun tutorials please
comment section
and peace see you next time thanks
hey all right so before actually ending
this video i was hooked up with a
android developer team on free good camp
by
oh mr or sac queen celeste
quincy all right um yeah so quincy i'm
sorry if i'm pronouncing that wrong yeah
so i was hooked up with a new free code
application that's actually been created
so i'll send
the preview mode so i'm gonna explain
how it works in this application so
basically this is just uh
within the preview mode the application
is staying progress so you guys should
just wait for it turn out for it's
unjust you know he doesn't need this
letter to regret that to get an update
that the app is uh sorry launch make
sure you just subscribe to it because
their app is actually bunga so it
actually has everything you need so this
actually if we could come application
here
so what this does is it fetches
the news field from the
um frequent camp itself so it's sort of
like heading over to fruitcoco.com uh
figured out that all you can basically
just open difficult application in front
and you can dive into what you want to
read all right so i have this um post by
andy and yeah yeah if you click on it
here you can see this is a this is an
actual posts that you can actually read
and there's also other options where you
can proclaim for offline user so in case
you want to read this
when you're offline when you're not
online you can actually bookmark it i'm
just going to invoke my blank i'll open
this in the browser actually so this is
going to open
the
um
the blog post in the url you can see
exactly what we have there is being open
there
so the app is staying in progress so
there's a lot to come you can see the
new city so we have the link so this
line is just
a part of the website where you
sign up to learn how to code for free
that's what it's called free code cap
where you learn how to code for free so
you can go ahead and just get started
just log in and start using
your the mobile app sort of you to like
go to the website save you down and then
or
or when you're not on a laptop and when
your laptop battery is there like we are
in nigeria there's no light to
everything you can just go ahead and use
your mobile the mobile application use
your mobile phone and just land on the
go so we also have podcasts where you
can listen to broadcast you can also um
download podcast
yeah so this is working yeah so that i
think that's working on the podcast
feature here so you see you see on
progress you see
in development process of the way i'm
reviewing this so you guys should stay
tuned for it it's going to be out so we
also have the radio where you like
listen to radio i actually don't know
there's code radio where you're
listening to free could come from radio
stuff actually i don't know but this is
actually amazing so you're listening to
the um 247 music design for coding okay
so this is um
i think i think this is a music design
for coding yes so if you want to call it
the type of songs you should be
listening to i think this is what it is
about
all right
then the last one otherwise is the
donate button yeah so you every little
support you give to fake epsilon
so even though it's around five dollars
um two dollars one dollar and the amount
to donate is actually
very good so just go ahead and help i
post two more so you can see the app is
actually good so we can see our bookmark
there
so um sorry
i mean if i should go out and like um
mark this i think i should be able to
see it in the bookmark here i can be
able to open it back
right so the same way i can just unbook
mark this
right so this is not here yeah you can
also search for articles you can see
latest articles here how to build um in
circuit cloud which reactancy wow so
this yeah the one that i like about
free code computer it has excessive
intensive knowledge
i i literally don't see the reason why
you should grind on ice because it's
where you can actually don't slip
this
just a instagram problem that covers
almost everything reactancy firebase
first or redux and expo
yeah
as soon as it becomes a written interest
um basically not less than six hours
five hours
i don't know
this is actually an amazing start if you
want to build complex application and
the same way there's a lot of things you
can learn javascript how to write even
good documentation as a documentation
when you're contributing
to open source or you're building our
open source projects you should be able
to write due documentation a lighting
accurate nodes are like is listed over
there so i like to close don't neglect
and prequest knowledge yeah so knowledge
that you think uh yeah and unless you
don't ignite it just add everything you
think it's possible to be added
all right so yeah that is just being
tested when you are writing a good
documentation and um
yeah everything you need is actually in
this place here it's actually this place
here so the only thing i just found out
is that
for iphone users ios users yeah there's
a way you can actually call your phone
when i was teaching
web design in a school yeah i i have to
install a an app application for ios
just go to your app store and search for
code editor or html editor for
excel for just type html edit on your
app store or code editor so you're going
to see um some qualities or you can use
i don't know what i want to say
javascript or hopefully you see what i
want them on python or
whatever
okay hold on and uh yeah you know the
last time we talked about python theory
being the way we can run python yeah
there's another way you can run python
however so let's say you use tamax
because you know timeox has been
breaking down recently i think
the
is is not be updated so the pkga is
actually breaking down see what you're
going to do is stop python
right on here
i think it's actually breaking down
so let's wait for this to finish up
okay as you can see now what i'm seeing
so it's actually giving repositories
under materials or it is down yeah so if
you didn't like that when i've been
trying to store packages that are like
node.js um python with using pkg or ap
store so that's why i didn't recommend
that are you actually using this until
it's actually fixed yeah so it's fixed
don't worry you get an update from me
then um let's go to play store there's
another way you can run this
but the best way is actually to use the
pi droid in case you don't want to use
something like speed i can zoom space
and notice i use q python so q python is
also is also a python emulator you can
see this
so it does everything you actually need
the same way the python3 is and this is
just it has less space
but hydrator is more more relevant than
it
all right so um basically that is all
for this tutorial
and um
if you need more of how to code on phone
please don't forget to just comment down
below and i'll be able to okay so for
you if you need me to build a to-do app
using uh using django using laravel is
it called igniter for on your phone or
you even need a front-end um using tywin
css here which will be able to use the
cd and it says the node is not working
um the time workers know you should use
the cdn so just comment down below and
you will see what i'll see what i can do
into it alright see you next time and
peace